ça pour vous ça
ça vous fait du mal ça c'est pas nous ça
ça c'est pas nous et c'est ça représente
pas tout ce qu'on essaye de faire
derrière c'est gringo et Nico vous vous
êtes parce que vous me on en parler
pendant la pub vous êtes des passionnés
en fait c'est quoi vous vous entraînez
c'est quoi le Rodez expliquez au
téléspectateurs déjà faut différencier
rodéo et bike life by life c'est le son
pour moi c'est un sport c'est vraiment
moi je m'entraîne ça fait 6-7 ans je
m'entraîne j'ai arrêté le travail
récemment pour consacrer à 100% dans mes
vidéos etc d'accord mais ça fait 6-7 ans
je m'entraîne je m'efforce à m'entraîner
et derrière ça il y a un réel sport et
un réel art maintenant je comprends que
ici en France ce soit mal vu c'est ça
mon danger les autres et là je comprends
donc c'est pour ça que je m'efforce avec
la notoriété que j'ai etc de le faire
dans des endroits adéquats parce que
légalement on n'a pas le droit mais
entre je vais dans des champs enfin des
des endroits où il y a personne en fait
mais même comme ça on risque la même
chose que des personnes qui font du
rodéo justement mais justement et puis
bon surtout tu penses aux autres
c'est-à-dire c'est ça aussi ils disent
voilà ça peut mettre en danger voilà sur
les routes sur les coins c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué Nico toi tu cautionnes
ça ou pas tu cautionnes pas du tout
c'est en fait moi je fais je fais pas
pareil que que gringo lui va dans des
spots fermés c'est ça du moins où il y a
personne ouais toi tu fais quoi toi en
fait moi je vais en ville bon je vais
pas dans les centres dans des centres
commerciaux non plus je suis pas fou
mais je vais en ville mais pourquoi je
vais en ville c'est parce qu'en fait
même dans les spots fermés où il y a
personne on est dans des champs des
zones industrielles où il y a personne
il y a absolument personne et ben en
fait on se fait bouger d'ici par la
police c'est c'est leur boulot c'est il
y a pas de problème il y a pas de
problème à ce niveau-là pas différencier
le problème c'est où on met des règles
claires exactement il y a pas
d'alternative et en fait pas de problème
mais derrière il faudrait des
alternatives des endroits aussi
structuré de la sécurité etc est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas faire
comme le karting ce qu'on pourrait pas
faire des PI certainement
dédié au Rodeo et là comme ça il y a
plus de rodéo exactement il y a le
circuit Carole c'est la première fois
depuis plus de 15 ans c'est la première
fois ça il y a trois mois où ils ont
accepté de faire des sessions ouvertes à
la back life à la moto donc un autre
sport et c'est la première fois parce
que là on voit on en parle il y a des je
vous le dis il y a des il y a des
citoyens qui sont qui vivent la peur au
ventre
et ça c'est vraiment ça c'est une
minorité c'est peut-être 1 %, c'est
maintenant vous allez dans des spots
fermés donc des zones industrielles le
dimanche là où il y a rien du tout il y
a juste des mecs qui font de la moto
vous y allez il y a 100 personnes mais
par contre vous allez dans les villes ou
quoi que ce soit vous croisez jamais le
moto ça arrive jamais ça arrive une fois
tous les 100 ans et malheureusement il y
a des quartiers il y a des quartiers
dans les vidéos deux enfants 10 et 11
ans blessés à Rennes une date de 78 ans
qui a été grièvement blessée laissée
pour morte en 2020 à Toulouse une femme
qui a été tué à cause d'un Rodeo pareil
77 ans qui vivent leurs nouvelles donc
c'est pas une fois tous les 5 ans c'est
qu'il y en a et qu'il y a donc des
accidents donc moi je suis d'accord
monsieur vous avez raison visiblement
c'est quelque chose qui existe et qui
fait plaisir donc trouvons des solutions
et encadrant
mais je suis complètement d'accord mais
le problème c'est que moi en fait je me
suis fait saisir une moto que j'ai
acheté 7000 euros que je travaille tous
les jours de la semaine pour attendre le
weekend en fer je me suis fait saisir ma
moto
j'étais dans un spot fermé et en fait le
problème c'est qu'on a pas le droit et
c'est en fait c'est qualifié de
urbain c'est exactement la même chose
que si on allait en ville et bah du coup
bah moi je vais pas rester sur un spot
ou la police ils peuvent venir me tuer
facilement et prendre ma moto
on ouvre une piste bah à circuit Carole
de toutes les sessions j'y étais j'ai
payé j'ai payé 50 € pour 3h de session
je les paye moi je veux pas mettre des
gens en danger je veux pas mettre mon
futur enfant ou une grand-mère qui
traverse la route moi je veux juste
faire de la moto j'ai envie j'ai envie
d'apprendre j'ai envie d'apprendre de
nouvelles techniques parce que alors toi
c'est s'il y avait des circuits dans
toutes les villes de France où on
pouvait exercer du rodéo tirer je
t'arrêterai d'aller dans les villes
arrêter d'aller dans la ville je paye
bien sûr tu es sûr parce que est-ce que
c'est pas du tout
il y a des personnes qui aiment aller
dans des défis
non c'est ça le problème les trois
quarts 90 % des personnes qui font ça
ils veulent apprendre ils veulent
s'entraîner et ils vont aller dans un
camion une heure de route prendre notre
canon pour aller dans des endroits où on
s'est souvent viré juste le truc c'est
que en faisant ça tu penses que on va
pouvoir être même plus répressif avec
ceux qui font ça en ville moi je suis
complètement d'accord voilà c'est ça
des structures et derrière bien sûr mais
je suis d'accord depuis tout à l'heure
je les écoute avec attention et
effectivement ceux qui pratiquent de
façon sauvage bien sûr
[Rires]
[Musique]
la sécurité publique non mais bien sûr
il s'en peut plus les policiers
évidemment parce que le risque il est
autant pour eux mais surtout pour les
gens qui sont malades quand on se dit
parce que là tout le monde parle que de
ça en ce moment quand on dit on crée des
pistes en France par contre en France
est-ce que donc on pourrait faire on
pourrait être beaucoup plus répressif
pour ceux qui sont fermés bien sûr il
faut trouver une équilibre c'est de
retour à mon avis sur a ouvert ça peut
le faire ça mais complètement
pour les gamins donc ça je trouve que la
soirée télécent de faire et par contre
taper sur ce truc
vous allez récupérer le nombre de gens
puisque ceux qui sont comme vous qui
sont qui sont cortisés voilà qui devrait
passionnés ils iront faire des choses
dans les dans le cadre de la loi et puis
les autres ce sera des irréductibles ils
seront une minorité et cela
effectivement la justice
ce qui est chouette c'est une super idée
de de faire des pistes comme ça donc la
France entière parce que les personnes
justement comme vous ne pourront plus
dire oui mais on peut pas c'est pas
encadré on peut pas le faire ailleurs
qui veulent faire du rodéo de mettre de
se battre pour essayer d'encadrer les
choses parce que personne ne va le faire
à votre place parce que nous nous qui ne
le faisons pas on s'en c'est
vraiment c'est un voeux pieux il faut
pas être hypocrite votre initiative elle
est loi mais c'est un vœu pieux les
rodéo là dans les centres commerciaux ça
passe par des réseaux sociaux des des
défis lancés tous les gens qui font ça
aujourd'hui à Carrières-sur-Seine une
petite fille de 10 ans qui a été percuté
sauvagement heureusement si je puis dire
elle n'est blessé qu'au genou
qui font des rôdeurs ils n'iront pas sur
vos pistes ils veulent défier la police
ils veulent faire ça en pleine ville
vous le savez très bien personne pour en
parler j'en fais tous les jours tous les
jours dès que j'ai fini le travail sur
moi
on me donne une piste on me dit tu payes
même 50 € la journée et je l'ai déjà
fait j'ai toutes les sessions qui ont
été ouvertes au circuit Carole j'y ai
été passionnant mon but vous savez c'est
pas c'est la ligne de la police quoi que
ce soit c'est apprendre des figures
apprendre de plein d'autres choses sur
une moto c'est est-ce que vous êtes
majoritaire des gens comme vous ou
est-ce que vous êtes
c'est la passion c'est le sport qui
prime nous on voit vraiment ça comme un
sport et un art est-ce que c'est la même
adrénaline sur la route que sur le
terrain on va pas voir les informations
mais si on n'a pas le choix la façon est
pas saute il y a eu il y avait des je
vous dis des bêtises il y avait des
sports de rue c'est à dire la box de rue
et ça y est il y a la box qui existe
maintenant bien sûr ça on peut encadrer
les choses on peut faire des choses on
en parle pas ouais il y a plein de
combats je regarde maintenant c'est
légal depuis très longtemps en France
exactement
elle est quand même minoritaire
il faut leur donner
c'est formidable parce qu'en fait on est
d'accord on pensait exactement que la
même chose moi je pense que
effectivement ces jeunes là qu'on voit
dans les centres commerciaux qui font du
Gym canin entre les entre les piétons en
fait ce sont des racailles ce sont des
voyous en fait ce sont des j'ai pas dit
j'ai pas dit Nico et une racailles ou
gringo
de criminels en puissance et quand on
renverse des vieilles dames une dame là
des enfants 84 ans elle a été renversée
parce qu'elle sortait ses poubelles et
qui est morte ou le jeune garçon qu'on a
reçu l'autre jour là un militaire qui a
été tabassé héros et de coup parce qu'il
a voulu arrêter les rodéo sauvages et il
était tué parce que les mecs comme ça
l'ont tabassé à coup de là j'estime que
c'est de la racaille c'est des voyous
c'est des criminels en puissance pas
voilà je ne vous vous
gênez-vous moi ça m'a gêné parce que
c'est pas grave pour vous ça s'appelle
comment ça les vidéos là en fait nous ce
qui nous gêne c'est des associés ah par
exemple moi perso moi je connais
personne qui fait ça
en fait
toujours du négatif
négatifs qu'on invite quelqu'un qui est
vraiment dedans et qui montre le côté
positif et moi je vous dis honnêtement
on est plus de 90% à pratiquer ça comme
on peut au jour d'aujourd'hui donc allez
prendre un camion aller dans une ligne
mais de l’essence on fait des 1h de
route on perd tellement d'argent pour
des fois durer 10 minutes et se faire
virer pour la gendarmerie j'imagine
aussi qu'il y a beaucoup de motos sans
immatriculation de moto volet de mineurs
qui font ça 12 ans 13 ans 14 ans
bien sûr mais ces articles ils vont ils
vont pas parler du positif il y a très
peu d'articles qui parlent du positif
c'est pour ça que je suis là mais c'est
génial j'en ai j'en ai quatre je les
achète à Yamaha j'ai la facture à
l'appui j'ai tout mon argent de côté il
est dans mes bras et en fait tous ceux
qui sont passionnés c'est pourquoi vous
avez une cagoule alors vous monsieur
puisque vous êtes un passionnés que vous
êtes complètement dans les
commentaires
de soirée
et ben pourquoi parce que moi ce que je
fais c'est vraiment par passion et en
fait je risque exactement pareil que ces
personnes là qui risque vraiment qui
font vraiment plus grave que chez moi
c'est aussi dangereux que centre
commercial
c'est pour dire que je le fais dans la
ville mais j'aimerais apprendre
l'alternative qu'il faudrait arrêter de
le faire dans la vie monsieur parce que
malgré tout même si vous pensez être
maître de votre véhicule ah non il peut
y avoir un accident et vous pouvez
désagrément hein
désolé la fille par exemple qui a été
renversée ou les enfants qui sont
renversés imaginons que c'est paramètres
comme moi qui veut que ça soit légalisé
bah cette personne serait jamais arrivé
parce qu'il serait dans un spot fermé là
où il y a personne en fait il y a plein
de choses après je dis pas que ça
arrêtait je dis pas que ça arrêterait ça
va forcément réduire
moi comme je suis con quand même manche
à balais j'essaye de comprendre en fait
non non mais j'essaye de bah déjà ta
phrase commence bien
lucidité déjà c'est quoi la différence
que vous kiffez les motos de cross vous
kiffez les sensations vous kiffez les
figures c'est quoi la différence entre
des spots de mecs qui font de la moto de
cross qui vont en forêt faire du trial
et tout qui kiffe toute la journée sur
une moto et vous qui demandez une piste
ça ressemble à quoi votre piste une
ligne droite c'est ça un cercle il nous
faut juste goudron
je vais faire des roues et faire des
roues c'est pas que des roues arrières
monsieur vous pouvez aller dans le
jardinier on va faire des figures on va
acheter une maison
partout en France de terrain de cross
des terrains
de faire du ping-pong c'est la même
chose mais c'est pas vraiment la même
chose nous ce qu'on aime c'est faire des
rois arrière faire des figures à prendre
c'est tout discipline différente
moi je suis contre la pratique des rode
urbains mais celle qui me rend vénère
c'est Géraldine
ils vont finir ensemble
je déteste inacceptable
parce que Géraldine c'est évidemment
connoté vous le savez très bien
mais bien sûr c'est cité banlieue c'est
un terme dans l'étymologie extrêmement
méprisante ce sont des délinquants mais
pas des racailles racailles
qui font ça c'est des personnes qui sont
notés
[Rires]
ce que je crois ce que je crois Cyril
c'est qu'il faut trouver une sortie en
consensus avec l'État les autorités pour
trouver un équilibre juste équilibre
des délits on fait des stages de
citoyens on fait tout un tas de choses
qui sont qui sont qui sanctionnés tu
t'en fous de ce que je dis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
exactement exactement
puisque c'est passé du contratventionnel
en délictuel ça avec des prisons avec
des milliers d'euros à payer etc on voit
pas la solution
il y a des stages des citoyenneté qui
sont donnés par le procureur de 1 à 4
jours qui permet de sanctionner ou tout
au moins de faire de la prévention aux
jeunes qui pratiquent mais c'est pas
c'est suffisant donc un moment donné il
faut trouver une véritable réponse il
faut discuter avec les élus localement
mais avec l'État c'est pas que c'est pas
assez suffisant peut-être que ces jeunes
qui sont en quartier et qui sont
toujours des connards qui vont continuer
c'est ça il y aura toujours
une opportunités
je pense que vous avez trouvé votre
style
mamie excuse-moi de te déranger pendant
la soupe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et puis c'est tout on va te mettre super
ça dans les mouton
mais moi je pense que ça peut réduire
mais j'ai un petit peu de mal quand même
je vois toujours des agneaux à notre
table et puis après on voit des
comportements je suis désolé
passionné de quelque chose si on ne peut
pas le faire dans la légalité on ne le
fait pas donc vous allez en bas oui mais
monsieur on est tous des frustrés de
quelque chose je suis désolé donc à un
moment on peut pas entendre faire ce
qu'on veut juste si ça dérange les gens
pour voir l'encadrer madame mais oui
simplement je pense qu'il faut
évidemment réfléchir à ça mais voilà
votre discours et de toute façon on peut
pas nier que par exemple ce genre de
comportement qui est quand même pas loin
de la racaille il y aura des il y a en
ce moment c'est la tendance
bravo et pour condamner plus fermement
il faut qu'ils aient des pistes comme ça
au moins on va et quand j'ai acheté le
fond dans la rue ben là on va les
défoncer même ce sont des racailles
avec ça vous allez réveiller la personne
je vous dis arrêter
de faire de la moto c'est tout si ils
nous disent arrêtez de faire de la moto
dans la ville vous avez des pistes à
payer tous les ans tu viens plus en
soirée